[Applaudissements]
ce que vous pouvez identifier un élément
commun à ces deux photos photos duo a
été prise à trégrom dans la campagne
bretonne et la photo du bas sur la plage
de saint michel en grève donc à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de très grave
éléments comme un bonjour un tracteur
aussi alors il n'y a pas que ça on
retrouve dans ces deux endroits
un élément qui est pas visible à l'oeil
nu mais qui pourtant est bien présent
cet élément c'est la zot
ça c'est un élément chimique qui est
présent dans les excréments des animaux
typiquement les élevages intensifs de
porc et de volaille comme on peut voir
sur la photo du haut à trégrom
produisent de la zot en grande quantité
note un élément chimique qui est présent
également dans certaines zones côtières
sous forme de nitrate où il est associé
parfois à des phénomènes de marée verte
c'est-à-dire à la prolifération massive
d'algues vertes
ce qu'on voit dans la baie de saint
michel en grève sur la photo du bas une
prolifération massive d'algues vertes
ici des ulves
façon extrêmement fréquentes en bretagne
mais se produisent aussi ailleurs en
fait c'est un phénomène mondial
olympiques de pékin en 2008
les épreuves nautiques étaient
organisées dans la baie de qingdao en
chine
une telle marée verte en 2008 dans cette
baie de qingdao était obligé de déployer
dix mille personnes pour ramasser toutes
les algues vertes avant de pouvoir
lancer les épreuves olympiques nautique
relier un peu rapidement azote nitrates
à marées vertes
je vous propose qu'on voit ça un peu
plus en détails ça qu'on commence par
concocté une petite recette de marées
vertes sont des ingrédients dont on a
besoin pour fabriquer une bonne marées
vertes
mira ingrédients assez intuitif les
algues n'ya pas de génération spontanée
on a besoin d'un petit stock d'algues
initial qui quand les conditions seront
bonnes va proliférer et se transformer
en marées vertes
ziehm ingrédients configuration de la
cote ou une cote qui soit capable de
retenir un petit peu l'eau de retenir
les algues d'empêcher un brassage
continue avec le large
c'est pour ça que les marées vertes se
développent principalement dans des
baies un peu fermé bien malgré diantre
est important la lumière que les algues
fond la photosynthèse
c'est à dire qu'elles utilisent
l'énergie du soleil pour fabriquer leurs
molécules organiques les molécules qui
les constituent pour ça que les marées
vertes se développent au printemps en
été quand il ya du soleil pour ça aussi
qu'il faut une profondeur d'eau assez
faible quelques mètres et puis nos pas
trop troubles il ya malgré dian les
nutriments des substances nutritives les
aliments si vous préférez que les halles
certes elle utilise l'énergie du soleil
ils ont aussi besoin d'une matière
première pour fabriquer leurs molécules
organiques matières premières c'est le
cas robben potassium celle phosphore
c'est là zot une potassium
il y en a dans l'eau de mer
naturellement ce n'est pas trop un
problème y en a beaucoup
phosphore à zot y en a aussi dans les
zones côtières naturellement en faible
quantité sous forme d'eau pour le
phosphore sous forme de nitrate pour la
zot phosphates et nitrates sont aussi
produits par les activités humaines et
des recherches ont été menées pour
déterminer les rôles respectifs des
phosphates et des nitrates dans la
prolifération des algues vertes
tiens des années 80 chercheurs comme
alain menesguen de l'ifremer brest
montré que les phosphates ne sont pas
limitant à la prolifération des algues
vertes en zones côtières
ça veut dire c'est que vous pouvez
ajouter des phosphates dans les baies
pas forcément conseillé si vous le
faites vous n'observez pas
d'augmentation katif des marées vertes
ah ça a été vérifié en grandeur nature
malheureusement parce que les premières
actions menées par les collectivités
publiques pour essayer de limiter les
phénomènes de marées vertes sont
complètement paradoxale avec les
résultats des recherches scientifiques
premières actions ont porté sur la
diminution des phosphates d'origine
urbaine
on a observé une diminution des
concentrations en phosphates et aucune
diminution des marées vertes en
conséquence ce que les recherches
scientifiques ont montré c'est que les
nitrates e100 limitant à la
prolifération des algues vertes en zones
côtières
donc si vous mettez plus de nitrates et
20 globalement vous aurez plus dingue ça
se vérifie très bien aussi en grandeur
nature des données de ce type là c'est
la baie de douarnenez vous avez en bleu
les flux d'azoté a porté par un fleuve à
la baie de douarnenez les flux de
nitrates
puis les bas rouges vous montre la
surface couverte par les algues vertes
en fin d'été vous n'avez pas de mal à
voir que les années où on apporte plus
de nitrates et bien l'étendue de la
marée verte est plus grande
plusieurs voulaient fabriquer une bonne
marées vertes
ayez la main lourde sur les nitrates
ayez la main lourde sur la zone vous
pouvez vous le procurer assez simplement
dans l'agriculture intensive tout formes
organiques dans les excréments d'animaux
sous forme minérale dans les engrais
azotés fabriquer artificiellement exprès
pour enrichir les sols en azote
voilà vous êtes bien avancé vous savez
fabriquer une bonne marées vertes
je trouve que les marées vertes c'est
plutôt quelque chose de désagréable
désagréable pour les populations locales
même dangereux parce que la putréfaction
des algues vertes libère un gaz toxique
h2s ce désagréable écosystèmes locaux la
prolifération tellement massive d'une
espèce évidemment déstabilise les
écosystèmes locaux
ce qu'on essaie de faire je pense que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi c'est plutôt
de rater la recette d'éviter les marées
vertes pour rater la recette c'est très
simple c'est comme n'importe quelle
recette
il suffit d'enlever un ingrédient
si on pense à la baie de saint michel en
grève hier disparaître le stock d'algues
initial c'est pas évident c'est même pas
possible les ulves sont des espèces
naturellement présentes dans les eaux
bretonnes en petite quantité de la
configuration de la baie n'en parlons
pas tarder le soleil ce serait un peu
dommage c'était nutriments en
l'occurrence la zot les nitrates
question qui se pose c'est de combien
est-ce qu'on doit baisser nos apports en
nitrates est ce qu'une diminution
modérée des concentrations en nitrates
dans les fleuves suffira à faire baisser
de façon significative l'ampleur des
marées vertes
la réponse est non
les études récentes du ceva et de
l'ifremer montré que si on voulait
diviser par l'ampleur des marées vertes
dans la plupart des baies bretonnes avec
les concentrations en nitrates dans les
fleuves passe en dessous de 10 à 15 mg
par litre
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des fleuves
tombé à 30 40 50 milligrammes par litre
de nitrates voire plus c'est en dessous
de 10 mg par litre nitrates ça implique
un changement drastique de nos pratiques
agricoles c'est pas des petits
changements à la marge qui vont résoudre
ni même diminué les marées vertes
ça va sans dire changer les pratiques
agricoles pour des citoyens non agréé qu
est ce que ça va changer drastiquement
ses pratiques alimentaires
deuxième question si aujourd'hui on
change drastiquement nos pratiques
agricoles si aujourd'hui on arrête
dépendre des surplus d'azoté sur les
champs
que l'été prochain où l'été suivant on
verra disparaître les marées vertes
la réponse est non on peut le deviner
en regardant ce graphique
si vous regardez bien en bleu
l'augmentation de l'utilisation des
engrais azotés commence dans les années
1950 où jean l'augmentation des
concentrations en nitrates dans les
fleuves
ici la vilaine le fleuve qui traverse la
ville de rennes commence plutôt dans les
années 75 80 là on pointe du doigt un
délai entre le moment où on épand les
engrais azotés sur les champs le moment
où on retrouve les nitrates dans les
fleuves délai voit l'eau souterraine
parce qu'en fait la plus grande partie
de l'eau de pluie qui tombe sur un champ
ne rhuys ne pas directement vers les
ruisseaux s'infiltre dans le sol c'est
là qu'elle se charge en nitrates et
ensuite s'infiltre plus profondément
dans les fractures de la roche ne peut
circuler très lentement plusieurs années
plusieurs dizaines d'années
avant de ressortir en surface dans les
ruisseaux clos souterraine piège les
nitrates dans la range qui finiront par
ressortir un jour dans les ruisseaux et
à ce moment là par être amené très vite
à la mer je suis un petit peu pessimiste
quand je dis nitrates qui finiront par
ressortir dans la roche
l'eau souterraine rencontre parfois des
bactéries qui sont capables de dégrader
les nitrates
comment et font comme nous avec
l'oxygène en fait au lieu de respirer
l'oxygène est respirent les nitrates
il ya une chose c'est que c'est un peu
plus facile
un peu plus rentable de respirer
l'oxygène que de respirer les nitrates
pour ça que les organismes qui vivent en
surface dans les ruisseaux dans les
rivières par exemple là où il ya de
l'oxygène
il préfère utiliser il laisse les
nitrates
un peu comme nous
revanche quand on s'enfonce dans les
profondeurs de la roche on trouve des
endroits très pauvre en oxygène ou dans
ces endroits les bactéries n'ont pas le
choix et prennent ce qu'ils ont en
l'occurrence les nitrates
nous ça nous arrange parce que c'est une
épuration naturelle de l'eau souterraine
qui est bien évidemment partiels
on vient pour conclure sur la notion de
délai entre le changement des pratiques
agricoles et la diminution de l'ampleur
des marées vertes
les deux photos que j'aurais dû mettre
en relation au début c'est plutôt celle
là la campagne bretonne dans les années
80 90 j'en conviens j'exagère un peu
avec le noir et blanc que j'aurais dû
mettre en relation avec les marées
vertes en baie de saint michel en grève
aujourd'hui que la zot qui provoque les
marées vertes actuelle provient en
grande partie des engrais est pendu il y
a vingt trente ans
terme les rites aujourd'hui des nitrates
de nos parents ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut rien faire que ça sert à rien au
contraire ça veut dire qu'il faut agir
tout de suite sinon à leur tour nos
enfants hériteront de nitrates
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]